we would feel very differently about
matt ryan if he had that one super bowl
win under his belt chris but you know
given where this guy's been 11 seasons
in the nfl third overall pick out of
boston college in 2008 he's put together
very quietly a great career number 12 in
passing yards and the sky's the limit
for the guy 46 000 yards and he's only
what 31 32 years old he's still got
plenty of time left to play maybe he's
32 and we see guys playing in the late
30s 34 okay well either way he's still
got plenty of good years left 31 32 34.
they're all younger than me so who cares
what the difference is between a year or
two here or there but he's got plenty of
good years left and uh who knows where
he's going to end up and i think he's
getting to that phase in his career
where we need to start appreciating
number one he's done some great things
and number two there aren't a whole lot
of years left for him to continue to do
them and football is going to be
different when he's not part of it
definitely i mean first off that super
bowl play we just showed there we got a
note that wasn't matt ryan's fault it
was devonte freeman he's supposed to
block dante tower he didn't block him
you know that's so that's not matt
ryan's fault even though everybody wants
to blame him there but i mean i hear you
mike i mean the guy has done
a lot of great things through his career
and the falcons have been relevant
pretty much every year throughout his
career but yeah where is his legacy i
mean no super bowl win of course his
biggest moment is gonna be a super bowl
blunder and the fact that they gave a 28
to three or blew a 28-3 lead i mean i
think that's what a lot of people think
of right off the bat when they think of
matt ryan you know had some
disappointing had an nfc championship
game where they lost to the 49ers and
they were winning that game they kind of
blew that lead too remember that mike
back in 2012. now you know what happened
to that end of that game navarro bowman
bad pass interference call not called
botched falcons probably should have
been the super bowl not the 49ers we
didn't change the rules that year though
for some reason uh so but i don't know
mike where where is this wait wait are
you suggesting we didn't change the
rules because it was matt ryan instead
of drew brees i i think that it it yeah
i think one team didn't throw a big
enough fit or maybe it would have been
changed at that point and a fan base
that didn't change it or throw a big
enough fit but regardless where is he
though seriously like matt ryan where do
you think he ends up is he a hall of
fame quarterback how does this all play
out
hard to be a hall of fame quarterback
without a super bowl win although
although dan marino dan fouts yeah fran
tarkinton i mean there are guys who have
made it to the hall of fame without
winning a super bowl right uh and and i
think a lot of it and i say this all the
time we we went down this rabbit hole
with donovan nab not that long ago i
look at championships longevity
statistics and dominance right and what
what you've addressed as it relates to
matt ryan's performance the past two
years not that it was dominant but the
fact that you can vouch for his ability
to make something happen when maybe the
system doesn't provide him with
something right now most football fans
aren't going to appreciate those nuances
and i don't know that the hall of fame
voters will either right but that that's
an example of a guy who rises above his
circumstance and uh it's just it's it's
hard it's hard to
yeah it's hard to to appreciate that
it's a lot easier to just say well he
won a super bowl even if he wasn't a big
player in winning a super bowl he's won
a super bowl right i i get that you're
exactly right and yeah i mean uh it is a
little more nuanced that way but yeah i
think ultimately we're almost talking
about matt ryan a little bit i feel like
the philip rivers conversation right
there's just not enough marquee wins or
moments yet for us to say
hall of famer or anything like that i
mean you know the stats are going to be
phenomenal but the guys that you talked
about with stats who didn't win the
super bowl their statistics were ahead
of their time right to where they were
like mind blowing fouts mourinho fr
tarkington they were kind of doing
things as far as numbers-wise
statistically like 10 years in advance
of the rest of the nfl and i think that
gave them the advantage as far as not
having that super bowl win you know this
day and age matt ryan's numbers are
great but they're not going to look as
sexy as of course drew brees or some of
these other guys so nfl legend at this
point but not a hall of famer i guess is
what i'm saying in my book well you know
targeting played the bulk of his career
before they loosened the rules and i
remember it was a big deal if he had 200
225 passing yards in a game and he
retired
as the guy with the top all-time passing
yardage and he's currently number 11.
just a couple hundred yards ahead of
matt ryan which tells you how the game
has changed from fran targa to being
number one 40 years ago to 11 to 10 guys
being past him and an 11th matt ryan
could leapfrog him the first week of the
regular season if that's how close they
are right now so i and and i get that
and it makes it hard to compare
quarterbacks from different eras but if
matt ryan finishes top five right now
he's got four he's got five active
quarterbacks ahead of him on this list
but he can pick off fran targeting
warren moon john elway he can easily do
that right um the question is how high
can he go could he catch it dan marino
he needs 15 000 yards to get there and
you know 4 000 yards a season you got
four more years you can get there i mean
i think he can get he could finish in
the top five six or seven uh the only
problem is for his era he's gonna be
number four five or six that's gonna be
the challenge right getting him to stand
out among his peers you know that that's
gonna be i think the biggest problem he
has because he's played at a time with
so many other great quarterbacks if you
get lost in the shuffle among those guys
how do you ever distinguish yourself and
get a bronze bus yeah i think you're
right that's the million-dollar question
and he's gonna have to do something to
distinguish himself all right so like i
mean i think we both agree if he wins a
super bowl he probably gets in what if
he just like won another mvp and got to
a super bowl and ended up losing do you
think that would be enough with his
numbers to get him in like a second i
think that probably yeah i think if he
finishes like number six on the all-time
passing yardage list i think that gets
him in by the way you guy aaron rodgers
he's way down there
he's number 17 and he's been a starter
as long as matt ryan you may want to
revisit your old time list there
christopher we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports